I have definitely experimented with hair colors
over the years.
I mean, I really have.
I've tried every color there is.
Blonde, black, red, platinum blonde,
black tips, you name it.
I have loved playing and I was really excited
when one of our viewers actually reached out to us
and she herself was in need of a refresh
and wanted, you know, a little assistance.
So I would love for you to meet Kelly.
Hi, my name is Kelly Kitley and I'm a Chicago native
with four children.
My husband and I have been married for just about 17 years,
and I am a psychotherapist and author.
My journey as a therapist and mother has truly evolved.
Having suffered from various traumas in my childhood
and throughout my life, I turned to alcohol
as a coping mechanism and really found myself
engaging in mommy drinking culture.
And looking at my children I knew I needed
to do something and change.
I have been sober eight and a half years
and it is paralleled with my journey as a therapist,
I mostly serve parents who have had alcohol
interrupt their lives.
It has been so fulfilling and I love that I can help others,
but it has truly been quite draining.
Mostly during this pandemic, we have all needed
more support than usual, and it has left me
less time to do things for myself
and I've been feeling a little burnt out.
I work on the inner me, but sometimes
I can't get to everything else
and getting my hair done is just
not been top of the priority list.
It requires a lot of time and maintenance.
So I usually just throw it up in this messy on Zoom.
Please Drew, I'm in desperate need of a hair refresh.
(audience claps and cheers)
Funny.
Funny how something like that can make
such a drastic change in our lives.
So we sent Kelly out for a day for herself
and give her a total hair rejuvenation.
So, please welcome the woman behind the make-over
you're about to witness and the best colorist
in the industry, period.
20 years we've been working together,
my dear friend, Tracey Cunningham.
(audience claps and cheers)
Well, you'll be happy to know that the hair
I have right now is a gloss that Tracey did
as a base color several years ago.
And I just kept it up and now it grew into this
and people are like, I love your color.
I'm like, it is one simple base process here, one here,
and I've been growing it out for years.
This is your color, Tracey.
We've teamed up with Redken
for Kelly's hair refresh and you're an ambassador with them.
You have been for so many years, and how amazing
that we could pick up the phone
and call the world's best expert, Tracey Cunningham.
So thank you for that.
Thank you.
What are some tips that you have for someone
who does wanna do a complete cover overhaul?
Okay.
First of all, do your research
before you get to the hairdressers.
And when you do bring only one photo.
Because sometimes people bring in five different photos,
they could be black and white.
They could be, you know, three different colored photos
and we put them all into our head.
And then we, we just, you know,
try to give you one look and it's not always perfect.
So just to be on the same page,
bring in one photo.
It's really helpful.
That's brilliant.
And in your book, "True Color,"
you feature a lot of brunette to blonde transformations.
So what is your advice to someone who wants
to make that big change?
Okay, so there are two different kinds
of people in this world.
There are people that wanna go blonde in a day,
and there are people with patience
that will book several appointments
and they'll know that each time they'll go lighter
and lighter.
The person that wants to go light in a day,
just make sure that your hair color has that time
and make sure that you're ready to pay
for three full head highlights in one day
because people do get sticker shock.
Okay.
Well, I would love to take a look at Kelly's look
before so we can refresh ourselves
on what she was looking like.
Okay.
Shall we drum roll?
Let's take a look at her now.
Kelly, come on out please.
(audience claps and cheers)
(upbeat music)
Whoa.
You like?
(audience claps)
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
It's so beautiful.
Holy cow.
Thank you so much.
Well, how do you feel?
I feel amazing.
It, I have been petting myself
'cause my hair is so soft and it's just manageable.
And I talked to my family and they were like,
mom, you look gorgeous over FaceTime.
And so it just, I have a little bit of a pep in my step
and that was even before I put on the dress and the makeup.
(audience claps)
Now, Tracey I wanna ask you.
When you looked at Kelly, what was your goal?
Like what did you look at and dissect
and where did your brain go to get to this hair color?
When clients say, I wanna be blonder,
do they mean here at the root?
I don't think so.
The blonde should be around the frame of your face
and the depth should be inside the hair
and the blond should be popping
your face is in your skin tone.
So I sent my friend Tyle Mahoney to New York
to do the transformation.
I knew he would be the perfect person for it
because he actually was the one who introduced me
to Shades EQ.
So Tyle and I talked about it and we thought
she definitely needed some lowlights,
some Shades EQ lowlights added in with some highlights.
And it just it's, it's so magical
what bringing your own natural hair color through
can do for the blonde.
It pops the blonde and it makes the blonde feel blonder.
And I think she looks so beautiful
with her natural blonde.
It looks beachy and beautiful.
I absolutely love it.
I think she just looks so amazing.
So-
And all you need,
all you need to do is ask your stylist
to do some Redken Shades EQ gloss.
It's so easy.
It only takes 20 minutes, but you have to go
to a professional and you will rock your own world.
And if you're feeling like you need a pick me up,
go to your stylist and they can give you a Shade EQ gloss
for a quick refresh and give you a gorgeous shine.
The Shades EQ really is my favorite line
when it comes to hair color.
Mine too.
It's literally given me super powers.
Yeah, no it's incredible.
Okay, Kelly.
So how do you feel
and what is tomorrow going to be like for you?
(chuckles) Well, I have to go out on the town somewhere,
'cause I feel fabulous, but. (chuckles)
Well, you look so beautiful.
Thank you so much.
And you're
a beautiful person inside and out.
And Tracey, I've known you for 20 years
and I thank you so much for doing this segment with us
and being such a good friend all over these amazing years.
Thank you so much.
(audience claps)
And Tracey and Kelly, thank you.
And we will be right back.
Thank you Kelly.
(upbeat music)